falcon heavy is one of the most powerful
rockets
ever built with a payload capacity of up
to 141
000 pounds with 27 engines on its first
stage
capable of producing over 5 million
pounds of force
the falcon heavy is no doubt a massive
rocket
and let's not forget about the best part
the synchronous landing of the side
boosters
unfortunately however despite spending
about seven years developing this rocket
spacex has only flown the falcon heavy a
measly three times
and though they have a couple of
launches planned for next year
it's likely that falcon heavy will only
fly a single digit number of times
before retiring so what happened to
falcon heavy
[Music]
well starting off the first major reason
that falcon heavy hasn't seen too much
flight time
is because it didn't exactly adhere to
the proposed timeline
this is completely understandable
because developing rockets
especially one as large as falcon heavy
is an extremely difficult task
at the same time though a lot can happen
during extended development periods
which can significantly reduce the
originally anticipated need for the
given project
elon musk announced the falcon heavy way
back in 2011
with the projected payload capacity of
000 pounds aside from this he planned
that the first falcon heavy launch
would take place in 2013. if we were to
be conservative
we could double the proposed time frame
and a reasonable expectation would be
falcon heavy taking flight
by the end of 2015 but unfortunately
this too wouldn't materialize you see
spacex was making rapid progress that
would make such a timeline
quite feasible but they would run into
some major obstacles with their falcon 9
rockets in 2015
and 2016 which would of course take
priority
in 2015 a falcon 9 rocket would
disintegrate soon after launch
and shortly following this incident in
a falcon 9 would explode on the launch
pad during a routine static fire
this led to the infamous clip of falcon
9 seemingly exploding before even
launching
aside from this the incident would
unfortunately lead to the loss of the
payload
which was a mo6 communication satellite
coming in
at a massive price tag of 195 million
dollars
evidently these back-to-back issues with
the falcon 9
raised some concern regarding the
reliability of the falcon 9 rocket
and considering that commercial falcon 9
launches are a significant portion of
spacex's revenue
ensuring customer confidence in the
falcon 9 was their top priority
which inadvertently pushed back the
falcon heavy to 2017
and as you would guess after some more
to be expected delays
we saw the falcon heavy launch on
february 6 2018.
the launch would be spectacular and go
down as one of the most iconic rocket
launches in history
however there was one small blemish
which is that the core booster would
fail to land and
would instead crash into the atlantic
ocean but
despite this spacex would be able to
line up two commercial falcon heavy
launches that were planned for later in
though these wouldn't actually take
place until mid-2019
with the last falcon heavy launch taking
place on june 25th
2019 there are four falcon heavy
launches
scheduled to take place in 2021 but
we'll have to see how many of those
actually come to fruition something
that's super ironic though
is that spacex is yet to launch the
first falcon heavy contract
they received in may of 2012 intelsat
gave spacex their first falcon heavy
launch contract
but intelsat would actually go bankrupt
earlier this year
so i'm not sure this will ever take
place anyways
as you can see during extended periods
of development your customers may lose
interest
find an alternative or go bankrupt thus
slashing original demand moving on aside
from taking a significant amount of time
to develop
the falcon heavy is quite a bit more
expensive than the falcon 9.
falcon 9 launches cost about 62 million
dollars
while falcon heavy launches run up to 90
million dollars per launch
now from a value perspective the falcon
heavy
is the clear choice as though it costs
one and a half times the falcon 9
it can lift nearly three times a payload
but
the thing is the volume of the payload
is identical between a falcon 9
and falcon heavy because the fairings
are the same
as a result the falcon heavy doesn't
actually provide any volume benefits to
the customer
the only reasons one would choose the
falcon heavy over the falcon 9
is if they have an extremely dense item
that cannot be handled by the falcon 9
which is quite rare or they need to
launch their device
much further into space like gto which
is the intended use case falcon 9 can
only carry 22
800 kilograms to low earth orbit but
falcon heavy can carry the same payload
plus more to geostationary transfer
orbit
but really how many customers need to
reach gto
today we have been accustomed to spacex
falcon 9 launches
every two weeks or so however commercial
launches
are actually still quite infrequent the
high frequency of falcon 9 launches can
be explained by spacex themselves
launching their starling satellites into
orbit
as a result when commercial use of the
falcon 9 itself
is not too frequent you can see why
falcon heavy
is rarely the choice of commercial
customers but then
why did spacex even develop the falcon
heavy
knowing that there would likely be
lackluster demand
well the answer is crude missions deep
into space
falcon heavy was designed to take
astronauts to moon
and even potentially mars here's the
thing
falcon 9 didn't really make sense for
crude mars missions
as the payload capacity to mars is quite
small
at 8 860 pounds while that may sound
like a lot when you factor in months of
supplies exercise equipment
sleeping areas toilets showers and much
more
falcon 9 isn't really all that feasible
for mars missions
aside from this we also have to keep in
mind that a mars mission will require
several supply runs to mars
before embarking on a cooled mission now
as we discussed before
falcon heavy wouldn't really make the
trip less cramped
but you could carry over 4 times more
pillow to mars
at 37 040 pounds if you're able to fit
it into the fairings
as you can see falcon heavy was expected
to make more supply runs
much easier and as for crude missions
up until 2017 spacex planned to send two
astronauts on a one-week trip around the
moon
in late 2018 using the falcon heavy
however in early 2018 elon musk would
knock out the idea
of using falcon heavy for crude missions
around the moon or potentially to mars
in favor of using the upcoming bfr or
starship rocket
and that brings me on to the next major
downfall of the falcon heavy
which is rapid development of starship
the thing is
starship far outperforms falcon heavy on
basically
every front starting with payload
capacity
starship is expected to be able to carry
000 pounds into low earth orbit or one
and a half times that of falcon heavy
theoretically starship is supposed to be
able to refuel
in space before heading to mars so it
should be able to carry the full 220
thousand pounds
straight to mars or six times that of
falcon heavy anyways
the case for starship becomes even
stronger when we look at pillow to
volume
the falcon heavy fairing is 17.1 feet in
diameter
and 43 feet in height treating the
payload like a cylinder
we get a pillow to volume of upwards of
10 000 cubic feet
meanwhile starship provides nearly four
times as much payload volume
coming in at 38 800 cubic feet
lastly the nail in the coffin for falcon
heavy is when we compare the launch
price of each of these vehicles
elon musk projects that starship may
cost as little as 2 million dollars per
launch
even if we quintuple that price target
to be conservative
starship would still only cost 10
million dollars which is a ninth of the
cost of falcon heavy
putting this together a six times larger
payload capacity
along with the ninth of the launch price
means that starship
is 54 times as efficient as falcon heavy
considering this it's a no-brainer to
wait and use starship for not only low
earth orbit starling launches
but also massive supply runs to mars
thus
essentially making the falcon heavy
obsolete
now despite all of these massive
advantages spacex hasn't fully signed
off on the falcon heavy
just yet elon musk has revealed that
he's open to use falcon heavy
for crude missions if starship
development takes longer than expected
but starship development has been moving
along quite smoothly indeed
and its first major flight test may be
complete by the time
this video comes out aside from this
spacex has been quickly building up
their super heavy booster prototype at
boca chica
and it is possible that they may even
reach orbit using starship
by the end of next year however 2022
or 2023 may be a more realistic
timeframe
nonetheless for the rocket industry
that's just around the corner
and with that being said it's quite
unlikely that falcon heavy
will end up being used for crude
missions in the meantime
falcon heavy may prove useful when it
comes to research missions funded by
nasa
earlier this year nasa announced that
they would be using falcon heavy in
admission to a metal rich asteroid
in july of 2022 so fortunately
we'll be able to see the beautiful
double booster landing for a few more
years
until falcon heavy is fully retired at
the end of the day
falcon heavy took significantly longer
than expected to develop
it serves a very niche audience and
purpose and
starship is rapidly coming to take its
spot
and that's why we haven't seen very many
falcon heavy launches
thus far and likely won't moving forward
will you guys miss falcon heavy comment
that down below
also drop a like if you guys are excited
for starship sn8 to finally perform its
first high altitude flight
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys
on the next one